forum des associations rime souvent avec
affluence au complexe sportif
brouaattrappe pour l'association
escalade ce forum est une première créée
en 2013 elle prévient et prend en charge
le décrochage scolaire chez des enfants
et adolescents de 5 à 25 ans elle
accompagne également les familles et les
professionnels en difficultés dans ce
domaine nous on propose une permanence
fixe dans les collèges et à partir de là
on essaie de les accompagner de manière
très régulière en moyenne une fois
toutes les de semaines pour pour la
plupart mais ça peut être plus fréquent
voire moins fréquent s'ils ont moins
besoin
d'accompagnement l'association
intervient dans les collèges le village
y Gagarine Gustave Courbet à trappe et
Alexandre Duma à morpa pour l'instant
elle cherche de la visibilité car elle a
encore besoin de se faire connaître
contrairement à d'autres comme l'étoile
des cheminaux de trappe né en 1937 le
club de basket ne rate jamais un forum
ça nous permet d'avoir de de nouvelles
familles des nouvelles personnes des
nouveaux jeunes on a des habitués qui
sont là depuis plus de 10 ans au club et
c'est vrai que bah renouveler un peu les
nouvelles générations et leur permettre
de pratiquer le basket c'est très
important pour nous l'année dernière le
club totalisit 230 licenciés il espère
faire mieux cette année grâce à
l'influence positive de l'équipe de
France masculine mais aussi féminine
lors des Jeux de Rio de